-Looking good, pal.
-Thank you.
-Thank you for
coming on the show.
-It's great to be here.
-Yeah, how's life?
How's everybody?
-They're good.
We keep having kids.
-Yes.
-Yeah.
-Congratulations.
You have a new baby girl.
-Yes, six months old today.
[ Cheers and applause ]
-Adelaide.
-Addy.
We call her Adelady-ady.
Addy. We're working on it.
It's new.
-Six months.
-Yeah.
-Does she have a personality
or anything yet?
-You know, we have
these two older kids
running around
and she just watches.
She's the watcher.
And we get the sense
that her whole vibe is
"You've got a lot going on.
I'm going to be chill.
And then maybe when I'm 8 or 9,
all hell's
going to break loose."
-Yeah, okay.
[ Laughter ]
You brought a photo here.
-Yeah.
-This is Ashe and Axel.
They're feeding --
-This is a great photo
right here of my family.
There you go.
[ Audience aws ]
First of all, he obviously loves
her if he's willing to
take off his mask
and reveal his true identity.
[ Laughter ]
-Batman would never do that.
-And this is -- Axel always
looks like a small-town mechanic
who's overcharging you.
[ Laughter ]
Oh, he just overcharges you.
He's like, "No, you need
a whole new engine."
[ Laughter ]
Yeah, and look at her eyes.
She's like, "Wait, I feel like
there should be a parent here."
[ Laughter ]
-That's so cute.
-It's really good.
-You also sent another picture
of Axel.
-Yeah.
-You said he has great style.
-He has great style.
And this is an outfit he put on.
-Okay.
-I want you to show
the outfit first.
-Yes.
-Because the minute
he put it on,
I realized he was dressed
like a film character,
a character from a movie
I know that we both love.
-Okay.
-And I want you to see you
if you can know based on the --
Who do you think
he's dressed like there?
-Let me see.
-Okay.
-He's very cute, first of all.
-Yeah. Thank you.
-Let me see there.
Yellow pants.
-It's the hair.
Ignore the glasses.
-Yep.
It's the hair.
Is it like a surfer?
Is it Brad Pitt or something?
-Alright, show it.
You're going to be mad.
-I am?
-Yeah.
-Dang.
Oh, my gosh.
[ Laughter ]
Oh, my God.
-It's full Wooderson, right?
-Alright, alright, alright.
-He's Matthew McConaughey
in "Dazed and Confused."
[ Laughter ]
Dude, that's so cute, man.
-Yeah.
-I love when they start
dressing themselves.
-We're doing pretty good. Yeah.
-Yeah. Not too shabby.
You know, in your stand-up,
"Lobby Baby," which is great,
by the way, you do a bit about
parents of three being more Zen.
You feel like there's Zen
with three babies.
-Yeah. And now I realize
it's just that you give up.
[ Laughter ]
I thought they found
some inner peace.
And it's more like, "Well,
there's just too many of them."
-Yeah, that's it.
That's the way you feel?
-Yeah, but the nice thing
about having three is
just the arrogance of telling
people, "Yeah, we have three.
Yeah. You have two, Jimmy?
Oh, my God. Two would be great.
Yeah, we have three."
[ Laughter ]
"You must have such a full life.
We have three."
[ Laughter ]
-We got to hang together
for a good little chunk
in Washington, D.C.
-It was the best.
-Because Lorne Michaels received
the Kennedy Center Honor.
And it was so much fun.
We hung out for like hours.
-It was great.
It was multi-generations
of "SNL" casts.
And we all were
just hanging out backstage.
And I was saying to people
afterwards --
You would be surprised to know
it, but all we did was
talk about the worst
we'd ever bombed.
None of us talked about,
like, doing well anywhere.
-Yeah, oh, yeah.
We're like,
"What was the worst you ever
bombed on this stage?"
And everyone had stories.
Kate McKinnon was even, like,
in the next dressing room.
She came out just to go like,
"I have a bomb story.
Yeah, I got on stage and just
got crickets. No one laughed."
-Well, because people don't
understand, a lot of times
we have to do things that are
galas or charity events.
-Yes.
-Where people might not want to
see comedy,
and then when you do it,
they're just confused
and a little bit angry.
-Yeah. They're there because
they're supporting the charity.
They're not really there
to see you perform.
-Yeah. And you walk out
and they're immediately like,
"I don't want this."
[ Laughter ]
-Do you remember
any painful ones?
-So, it was -- Remember there
was that Madison Square Garden
benefit for Sandy --
Hurricane Sandy.
-Yes.
-It was like the biggest bands
in the world.
-Yeah.
-And someone reached out
to Lorne and said,
"We'd love to have
'SNL' do something."
And the best Lorne could come up
with was me as myself
and Bobby Moynihan
as Drunk Uncle.
Drunk Uncle was an A-plus
"Weekend Update" character.
-Absolutely, yeah.
-Always crushed.
-Yes.
-Me and Bobby went out and did
Drunk Uncle, I think, between
The Who and Arcade Fire.
[ Laughter ]
In Madison Square Garden.
And I remember we were standing
backstage and it was starting to
dawn on us
this was a terrible idea.
-Yeah.
-And Chris Rock walked up to us.
And he just looked,
because Bobby was in costume,
and he looked at us and he went,
"You're going to do sketches?
[ Laughter ]
"You're going to go out there
and you're going to
do a sketch?"
It's like,
"Ladies and gentlemen,
give it up for The Who!
And now here's a sk--"
It was like
a high school talent show.
-It is so fun.
We kept talking about
those stories, and everyone
had bits, by the way.
Everyone was doing bits.
And like you said,
it was every generation of --
It was from Steve Martin,
Kevin Nealon, Amy Poehler.
Everyone was just
on fire and funny.
And I remember as we rehearsed
from like 12:00 to maybe 5:00 --
-It was a long rehearsal, yeah.
-I was leaving
and I was just kind of tired.
I wanted to just to get ready,
get a tux on, get back.
I'm leaving and they go --
I was getting in my car.
They have cars to take us
to the hotel.
And I get into my car, they go,
"Jimmy, Kevin Nealon wants to
say hi to you or he wants to say
something to you
and he's in his car."
I go, "Okay."
I go over to the car,
and Kevin's there.
I go, "Kevin, do you want me?"
He was just there.
He just rolled his window up
and then took off.
[ Laughter ]
That was it.
-That's fantastic.
-That's all he wanted.
-That's all.
-Funny, funny bit.
It was so good.
Pal, I'm proud of you.
Look at this one right here.
-There it is.
-"I'm Not Scared,
You're Scared."
[ Cheers and applause ]
Come on!
It officially came out today.
-It is.
This is the day
you can buy this book.
-Yes.
What inspired you to write this?
-It's so funny --
When you have kids,
they're scared of
a lot of things.
And I would say about half of
them, you want to tell them,
"Oh, that's crazy,
don't be scared about that."
And then the other half,
you, as a parent,
are so happy they're scared of.
Like traffic.
You don't want to tell your kids
like, "Don't be afraid.
Face your fears!"
[ Laughter ]
-Traffic is something
to be afraid of, yeah.
-So there's this weird thing of
I feel like you have to talk to
your kids in a way -- you can't
just tell -- you have to explain
to them why some fears are okay
and some are not.
And ultimately, kids have to
decide on their own
to stop being afraid
of something.
-That's correct.
-You cannot just yell at them
and tell them
to stop being afraid.
-I love the drawings,
by the way, too.
-Yeah. Rob Sayegh Jr. -- I want
to make sure I give a shout-out.
I did not do the drawings
in my book.
I did originally and they said,
"This is -- No."
-"Terrible. Please don't."
-They were like, "We're going to
need the money back."
[ Laughter ]
-When you read this
to your kids,
do you do different voices?
-They will not let me
do the voices.
-Aww.
-Yeah, no.
It's heartbreaking.
[ Laughter ]
It's a very passive-aggressive
way of saying
they don't care for me
as an actor.
[ Laughter ]
It happened to me at "SNL" too.
You know, I started as
a cast member.
A lot of people don't know that,
and then, after a few years,
Lorne was like,
"Should you do Update?"
[ Laughter ]
"I think your voice,
maybe just your voice."
-"Just do you maybe
behind a desk."
-Yeah. Lorne was like,
"Do we need the legs?"
[ Laughter ]
-Well, it worked out.
We're talking more to
Seth Meyers
when we come back, everybody.
Check out his new book.